la base en btt de un triángulo decrece
con una razón de 13 metros por hora y la
altura hdt del triángulo crece con una
razón de 6 metros por hora en un cierto
instante de cero la base mide 5 metros y
la altura un metro cuál es la razón o la
tasa de cambio del área adt observa todo
esto lo tenemos como funciones del
tiempo del triángulo en este instante
así que lo que vamos a hacer en este
ejercicio además de intentar resolver
esta pregunta será identificar las
unidades con las diferentes expresiones
justo aquí y además identificar cada
expresión con su valor dado por acá
claro si es que nos dan esa información
y todo esto nos ayudará a resolver la
pregunta sobre la tasa de cambio del
problema que tenemos primero hagamos
esta parte identifica cada expresión con
sus unidades y como siempre pausa el
vídeo
y puedes resolverlo por tu cuenta
bien la primera es de prima de té
bueno observa estás la razón a la cual
cambian la base con respecto al tiempo
así que si lo piensas sabemos que esto
está dado en metros es la base y sus
unidades son los metros y si pensamos en
be prima de t bueno en que se va a medir
o cuáles van a ser las unidades de b
prima de t bueno si lo pensamos un poco
aquí dice que el triángulo decrece con
una razón de 13 metros por hora
de modo que b prima de t está dada en
metros por hora en metros por hora por
lo tanto voy a seleccionar metros por
hora
esta de aquí ok después me dicen el área
en t sub índice cero bueno recuerda que
a es el área de nuestro triángulo es
justo lo que me dicen de aquí y como
hemos medido todo en metros puedes decir
que el área se va a dar en unidades
cuadradas
de hecho en metros cuadrados de lujo
ahora amd hd3d subíndice cero es decir
la altura en ese instante dado bueno eso
es muy fácil sabemos que la base y la
altura ambas se miden en metros por lo
tanto voy a seleccionar metros
esta es la unidad de esta altura y por
último tenemos la tasa de cambio del
área con respecto al tiempo ok
sabemos que el área tiene comunidades
los metros cuadrados pero aquí tenemos
la tasa a la que cambia el área con
respecto al tiempo por lo tanto será una
cantidad de área
unidad de tiempo y como el tiempo aquí
en este problema se miden horas entonces
éstos serán metros cuadrados por hora
entonces seleccionaré esta opción
de lujo ahora me dice identifica cada
expresión con su valor dado y primero
nos preguntan cuánto vale la base del
triángulo en el tiempo de subíndice 0
nos lo dan veamos en un cierto instante
t subíndice 0 la base mide 5 metros y la
altura mide 1 metro
aquí está en un cierto instante de
subíndice 0 la base mide 5 metros por lo
tanto la base que es una función del
tiempo entes o 20 0 va a ser 5 y por lo
tanto voy a seleccionar esta opción y
ahora que me puedes decir de la tasa de
cambio de b con respecto al tiempo nos
lo dicen pues si lo puedes ver aquí en
la primera parte de este problema la
base de dt de un triángulo decrece con
una razón de 13 metros por hora es decir
que la tasa de cambio de la base que es
lo mismo que b prima
que también lo podemos ver como debe
sobre de té está nos dicen que decrece
con una razón de 13 metros por hora esto
quiere decir que ésta será de menos 13
metros por hora porque decrece entonces
vamos a seleccionar por aquí menos 13 es
justo esto que tenemos de lujo ahora
vamos con la derivada del área en de
subíndice 0 esta es la tasa de cambio
del área con respecto al tiempo en el
tiempo de subíndice 0 nos lo dan bueno
es justo lo que nos preguntan cuál es la
razón o la tasa de cambio del área
adt del triángulo en ese instante por lo
tanto nos falta esta información y de
hecho si nos dieran esta información
pues no tendríamos problema que resolver
por lo tanto pondré
es lo que estamos intentando encontrar y
por último tengo h prima de t
para esto de aquí lo podemos ver también
como la derivada de h ok con respecto al
tiempo ok y te pregunto cuánto vale esta
expresión nos la dan bueno
observa justo aquí nos dicen la altura
http del triángulo crece con una razón
de 6 metros por hora así que nos dicen
que http está creciendo entonces nos
dicen que la tasa de cambios de hdt con
respecto al tiempo es positiva y además
que toman el valor de 6 metros por hora
de manera que seleccionar el 6 positivo
que es justo lo que tengo aquí
también nos dan este dato ahora porque
todo esto es útil para resolver el
problema bueno porque ahora ya estamos
listos para resolver la pregunta porque
si hablamos de manera general en
cualquier triángulo sabemos que el área
la podemos encontrar multiplicando un
medio por la base por la altura pero en
este caso la base y la altura y también
el área son función a este tema así que
puedo escribir esto como el área que
depende de ti ok esto es igual a un
médium ok de la base que es una función
del tiempo por la altura que también es
una función del tiempo ok y si queremos
saber la tasa de cambio o la razón del
área con respecto al tiempo en este
instante t subíndice 0 bueno primero
habría que encontrar la derivada de esta
área con respecto al tiempo es decir
aquí me quedaría que
prima de té ok esto va a ser igual a un
médium ok que multiplica y bueno
básicamente aquí hay que hacer la regla
del producto la derivada del primer
término con respecto a tema lo cual es b
prima de t
ok
y esto lo multiplicamos por el segundo
término por hdt ok y a esto le sumamos
el primer término tal cual está btt ok y
a esto lo multiplicamos por la derivada
del segundo término por la derivada con
respecto a t
ok h prima de t
del segundo término ok ya tengo toda
esta expresión y ahora no queremos sólo
la expresión general queremos evaluar
esta expresión en un tiempo de subíndice
cero por lo tanto queremos encontrar a
prima de t subíndice cero y bueno esto
me va a quedar lo único que hay que
hacer es cambiarla te portes 126 0 y por
lo tanto me va a quedar que a prima de t
subíndice 0 es igual a un médium que va
a multiplicar a de primer dt subíndice 0
por h
dt subíndice 0 + b dt subíndice 0 por h
prima de t subíndice 0
y ahora podemos sustituir porque nos dan
toda esta información cuánto es de
primer ente subíndice 0 bueno nos dicen
cuántos la tasa de cambio deben con
respecto al tiempo la base petete de un
triángulo decrece con una razón de 13
metros por hora y parece que es
constante en menos 13 metros por hora
así que tenemos esta información y luego
cuánto es
h ente subíndice 0 pero también nos lo
dan recuerda en un cierto instante de
subir desde cero la base mide cinco
metros y la altura mide un metro por lo
tanto tenemos cuánto mide la altura y
también tenemos cuánto mide la base y
además tenemos cuánto miden h prima
dt subíndice cero porque nos dicen la
altura
http del triángulo crece con una razón
de 6 metros por hora entonces aquí
tendremos que poner 6 metros por hora
por lo tanto tenemos toda esta
información sólo es cuestión de
sustituirla y encontrar cuánto valen la
tasa de cambio
la razón del área ente subíndice 0 así
que es momento de decir nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo